i'll give her a hysteria
i'll give it to her but it's it's we
talking to we tend to have sex
in the in the station and then going
back to your boyfriend and letting him
eat you out yeah that's which type of
behavior
is we exaggerate those sides of
ourselves and it's we're pushed to and
i'm not making an excuse for it at all
because yeah i agree that's it's not
great behavior but it's because we've
been um pushed to align ourselves with
one side either hypersexual or hyper
pure and it's because it's been
constantly separated over time that we
have to align ourselves with planet i'm
not saying it's a good thing
i'm not saying that's good at all but it
happens and i think it takes a certain
level of consciousness to be able to
step out of that which not a lot of
people have access so so to me i just
think girls like attention yep and so
but i'm saying i think girls especially
like we live off of attention that's why
so many girls are addicted to social
media where men are addicted to video
games would you say and so and so what i
would say is like girls that tend to be
more sexual got the attention from guys
and they liked it and they kept doing it
and that was like the positive feedback
loop but they didn't realize there was
consequences later and the girls that
didn't do that saw that there was
saw that they had the negative
consequences and therefore got the
positive feedback loop maybe had a dad
to tell them not to do it completely but
exactly you're giving it back to the
father if a father figure isn't present
to build that strong relationship with
masculine energy a woman is going to
seek out that attention that's true
that's true that's like daddy issues
yeah exactly yeah exactly yeah
yeah we don't need the father anymore
but that's why that's the father that's
why the father is so important in the
home remember right yeah no and i i
think the mask i don't think it's
necessarily a father i think it's a
healthy masculine representation which
is the problem and i think it shouldn't
necessarily be restricted to it would
you say in general or family dynamic
there are a lot of ways that people can
get those role models would you say in
general it's through a father like a man
yeah in general
so like if we go back and forth about
exceptions we'll be talking in circles
all day but then the father has to step
up as well as the mother but i i think
men in general like men have issues too
i'm not i'm not negating that men have
issues but like i just think men are
there's a large group of men that have
no purpose because they don't have women
because modern women are side chicks
because modern women keep sleeping up
and up and up because you know damn well
that you could sleep with a guy that
would never be seen in public with you
ever like like then that like yeah and
it's that's not fun but it's just true
like guys will have sex with a hole in
the wall right yeah guys
and you guys you ladies know that you
can be looking your words you can walk
out the house looking average and still
garner attention from it yeah men will
still give you attention
and so and so the thing is like if we
keep with birth control and the sexual
revolution it's a smaller percentage of
men that are having all the sex so that
means a larger percentage of men are
sleeping with nobody
and like that's what i'm saying it
starts with the women because if women
aren't creating families like that women
set the precedents
and i think it was rwanda or something
and it was basically looking at um who
like basically who got the women
and it would be the chief or whatever
they were called and then they would
have they would have multiple wives
you've seen that like all across the
world right that's never changed and
they did a study and they found that the
the first wife had the children with the
man and they were like the you know the
best they were like queen on top
children and then the other wives who
had
um babies with the a powerful man even
if they didn't have a hundred percent
exclusivity those children were better
off than
um if a woman had a baby and with a
monogamous man who wasn't so that's not
just in today's society that's literally
you're of since you're you're correct
like you're absolutely corrupt you could
make an argument for polygamy but the
difference was back then the women got
resources with it so it wasn't like like
nowadays you're just giving sex for free
exactly it's like back then you got you
might not have been first wife but you
could have been third or four like in in
muslim cultures we had a guy in here
that talked about how he had to marry
each and every wife of his and he had to
provide they were taken care of
financially forever
and so i'm not i mean i don't i don't
prefer the polygamous stuff but if like
someone wants to do it you can make you
can make an argument for it yeah but the
problem is women are getting taking sex
without the resources
and so
and and so
and so therefore they're incentivized to
get a kid off of a rich guy
women women don't understand that you
set the standard yeah okay for men to
have sex okay and because men generally
as much as men men even know we're quite
simple creatures yeah if the pussy's
there we'll go for it yeah okay and if
you have to understand that if you're
giving it away for free like literally i
can download the app right now right and
in an hour i can have sex like sex is so
readily available from women yeah that
men no longer have to work for it if men
had to work for sex yeah we wouldn't
have half of the problems that we're
having right now but i think but the
thing is women are giving away their
vaginas so readily so easily that men
are like oh well you know i don't have
to work for it like what what the hell
i'm women and then we'll scream man or
trash but
we set the standard yeah you have to
leverage sexual assault
yeah that's what it is you need to
leverage sexual access to get commitment
right just like a man you know leverages
like his commitment or his resources you
know whether that's physical protection
emotional security or um financial
security in order to gain access like
you need to do or we need to do a better
job of leveraging sexual access to get
commitment because if you're giving it
away for free then why why am i going to
commit i can get it from free
and then you go on a talk show on a
dating show with a guy that's just have
sex with you right in the morning
talking about oh yeah you know what i
want to date a guy what you just had a
penis inside you like because your
vagina is so readily available yeah you
have to understand seriously i think
women need to understand you are making
your vaginas too readily available okay
and then you cannot now complain that
men are trash because the bottom line is
if you don't set the standard if you
don't set the president because men
listen men will die free fire for [ __ ]
i'm telling you right they will die for
the fire for [ __ ]
ish knows
dave has a song don't die for yeah
yeah
right exactly but the thing is if it's
if you make it less red because like i
said if dave chappelle said if [ __ ] was
a stock
right
it would it would plummet it would be
plummeting right now because the market
has been flooded with it right so you
have to understand that if you flood the
market with something it no longer
becomes precious i think i think it's a
bit of laziness it no longer becomes
precious
i think that's why vagina's not precious
anymore why is there a need for it to be
precious why isn't it like oh man men
have been should have mentioned
there's another there's none if you want
to be a side chick but if you want guys
to commit to you then you don't value
you
you don't think your body's precious
i think my body's precious sex is sex
it's something to do because you want to
enjoy it it's not because oh hey this is
like
what is this guy going to give me so i'm
going to give him this it's just like oh
i don't know one day i might when i have
sex i'll do it i don't know i don't know
about that you can create life
talking into your mind a little closer
yeah i prefer like you're not having sex
with me like as a woman personally like
you can just go out and be like i wanna
have sex but like i if i like
definitely treat me like a princess
first like
don't just like you can't just enter and
leave
like i think
i don't want that you can't just go down
to the gas station have sex with me and
go back to my boyfriend but yes we can
yes yeah some women
are fine with that and that's their
prerogative and i don't think you should
if there's a you shouldn't control women
who want to do that and like
like make them feel bad about it because
that's you know there's a lot of people
with kinks out there men and women
involved
who are like into that but there's a lot
of people who are trying to make it feel
bad about
women to be like you're slagged so do
you do
do you have the same do you have the
same energy for men that don't want to
date girls with high body counts do you
have the same energy like that's your
prerogative you're allowed to do what
you want to do
or because a lot of times when i say
yeah because a lot of times what i see
is like there'll be things like [ __ ]
shaming and like shaming language
language when men want to have standards
but it's also like i don't think if if
you're a woman who doesn't sleep around
a lot i don't think you would want to
date a man who sleeps around a lot i
think you just probably find someone
who's on your level of shagging yeah but
a guy who sleeps around a lot is
definitely a guy who's provided value to
a particular extent because the vast
majority of guys can't do that you know
this is this is women are attracted to
men with sexual experts exactly like you
because you deal with the best guys you
think all guys are like that whereas the
reality is that that's a very minute
percentage of men